I want to be your loser pay big gift
well last week we can't wear skirt and
we didn't see anything but a lot of
creeps were ment commenting commenting
on it so we asked her if she wanted to
share some of her creepier weather the
and where do they comment on cats kurta
oh there was like YouTube comments but
that dander yeah but then we just asked
to see her DMS and she was cool with it
and she shared some of the weirder I
like how YouTube will censor us or D
monetize this for talking about gay
dudes and San Fran and salmon but then
let the comments go rampant freedom of
speech man do what the thing yeah but
the scum of the earth is on there so I
don't know if Kat would want to read
them I would rather not be recorded
saying these things probation
violates many orders Nick abiding by for
me once so this gentleman says he wants
to be he says I want to be your loser
pay pig do you have a paypal Loki want
to be your true but what's the pay pig
though he basically just wants to give
me money so you want you to be his sugar
baby kind of but just like there's
nothing really any for him other than to
give me man oh you accept the money it
makes him feel some sort of should we do
this sir I don't just send you money he
has zero followers so it's about
something people will send me these
things through burner accounts it's not
their actual account oh also I missed
rolls yeah keep going
burner that the Comedy Store this is a
[Laughter]
yes this is one of my personal favorites
he says can I slurp oatmeal out of your
ass and he said he used to send me this
once every like week or so god dammit I
like this guy first of all though the
word birch slurp makes you feel sick
what do you say oh my god oh my ass is
away a gentleman would ask slurp what
kind of degenerate uses the word slurp
no I gentlemen be like a good day miss
what's up the rear menu today with a
little sugar
I like that rear menu can i slurp
oatmeal out of your ass this guy is a
real foger guy apparently works at the
pawn stars shop he looks like he
definitely plays um he looks like he
probably plays center on a little person
back the newest member of pod stars dude
go traitors [ __ ] in pon de stars lives
in a small body of water and eat cat
food well if it's steel cut oats man
those are really good at low heating
acid oatmeal as a balanced breakfast
this one's my favorite art so this guy
he starts off by saying a likio but
clean for real for real oh sorry I meant
for real for real oh good thing he
corrected him beside oh my god I'm so
had a turn here oh my god sorry I mean
for real for real and this guy is do we
know anything about this guy or who is
he seems like that help he seems really
out picture he seems outlandish huh
these trolls know what if he dog though
in the pillars of the hug but if that's
just his owner
that's all that's the best offer yeah
but we feel like anybody's like what
they do
all dogs like ass we know this yeah this
has got to stop and they all don't go to
heaven don't get it twisted yeah and
first of all this dog is already
obviously dating a male crossing guard
we can get a tightening picture on that
guy
damn that scent and a basically 11:00 at
night what do you think he was doing
when he said that I am 11 yeah he
probably probably just finished watching
King this thing yeah that's what we're
gonna say he was like here we go
Thursday night saw you in the dress
what's this
oh this was a comment on one of my
photos
this guy says you told my grandpa
killing half of your people in the war
to get you to come to America well worth
the mandate and was out on Memorial Day
as if that was bonus points for this man
if the Memorial Day and also that's a
goddamn American if I've ever seen a man
k WB u RR s 1 1 1 - way to go man cat
with the quickness one minute she got
that screen shot in case this guy who
had any regret if it took my gun but
come on half year people know more to
get you to come to America oh yeah this
is 9,000 a fiancee we got one more this
one's probably the bluest but I don't
know I'm sure you're keeping it PG for a
friend Theo he made sure not to show be
too explicit once ok dick Nicks
oh yeah - Myka just show it drawing
maybe of them
this guy says I would suck your dad's
dick if I could smell your farm
what oh that one's border life I don't
borderline what allowed on the show I
don't know too much damn bouquet r94
yeah let's call these people this kind
of stuff aside let me get a real picture
of beau r94 yeah
just offer it look just keep it chill
man no before I sit this mom the hell
are you doing yeah they all generally
kind of look the same though I will say
only have a photo they generally have a
look the ghost of Christmas past this is
this is the last cameo the Jerry Sloan
ever did Jeff hornacek looks like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
horn check another transfusion Brian
Kilmeade Houston this week I like they
supporting Brennan's other endeavors
though there's a chance Ryan Callahan
Houston there's a chance we can't
guarantee amazing Friday
[Music]
nothing
[Music]